well youtube looks like i'm
back at it i'm following up on a video
that i did because youtube followed up
with me i talked with a real human
person from youtube
that sent me this very detailed email as
a lot of people have hit me up in the
past saying
hey i need to get in touch with youtube
about this thing and i've had to tell
them hey man we've been doing this for a
while
and it can be even very difficult for us
to get in touch with an actual human
being at youtube
but i got a human response here so this
follow-up video is because i did a video
a couple days ago
uh talking about how we got this
ridiculous copyright claim
on uh our reaction to the tom cruise
leaked audio and it wasn't the reaction
that got us to claim
it was the opening at the opening of it
we said the name
tom cruise kind of in the tune of the
mission impossible theme
song we don't make any instrumental
noises we don't do
anything like that it's our best it
qualifies as parody
but it's not even on key but that didn't
matter it was enough for these companies
to give us a copyright claim and take
the revenue from the video
as many people hit me up saying this is
obviously fraudulent i've had at least
two youtubers
who have over a million followers who
hit me up saying this has to be
fraudulent this is ridiculous right it's
ridiculous
all you i don't i feel like most people
would agree this is insane
so the whole email is going to be in the
pin comment without the guy's name here
there's a couple things i want to focus
on
because long story short here's what's
happening youtube has this thing set up
in place called content id
basically these copyright owners the
whole process of documentation that they
have
set up where they can do manual claims
on videos if it matches any of the
content id now there's usually two types
of copyright claims you'll get when you
upload to youtube if you're dealing with
something like that you get the
automated claim which is just like an
automated
detection system that they have set up
and then they have the manual claim
meaning some [ __ ] watched
our video and said screw these guys
manual
claim this and we'll take the revenue
from it and i was like
youtube you help out and when i first
talked with creator support
they said yeah we have a human reviewer
uh who will look over this and we'll and
we'll help you out with the claim we'll
we'll at least work on this with you
right come to find out
they're not going to now the whole email
is listed in the pinned comment but
here's a couple of things i want to
focus on with you guys but they're not
going to
so what it's actually all going to be in
the hands of the
people who claimed us the deciding
factor on whether or not
the copyright and like the video's not
really gathering any views now
uh that tom cruise wants so it doesn't
really matter because
youtube was constantly says something
like hey we'll pay out to the
appropriate owner after the claim is
resolved and
in my entire time i've been doing this i
mentioned this in the last video
i've only known one individual who
actually got his revenue back
on our end that's happening with us many
times especially with like companies
like netflix for example
they usually give us a copyright claim
and those and then after it gets like
all the views that we can get they're
like hey claim release you're good to go
and then we never get uh any revenue
from it it happens all the time it
surprised me to learn
the whole thing with the claim is not
going to be someone on youtube's end
going in to watch that
20 seconds the opening 20 seconds and
going wait a minute
this is insane you can't claim these
guys over this
this is stupid there's not going to be
one person from youtube doing that
it's all in that manual claimant that's
why i think a lot of times
people who do especially music video
reactions or even with trailer reactions
where they have like
five seconds of a song that gets their
whole video demonetized whenever it's a
music company that claims
i rarely have heard of a music company
letting a claim go here's the options
the claimant has
release the claim if they agree with
their dispute they can release their
claim
if you're previously monetizing the
video your monetization setting will be
restored automatically
when all claims on your video are
released uphold the claim
if they believe their claim is still
valid they can uphold it
they usually do if you feel it was
mistakenly upheld
you may appeal their decision i've never
won an appeal in my life take down of
you there's like
it gets to the point where nothing
starts feeling like fair use
takedown of the video they can submit a
copyright takedown request to remove
your video from youtube which means
we'll get a copyright strike because
there's two things there's copyright
claim
and there's copyright strike strikes are
really bad i mean copyright claims suck
but strikes
he had three of those bam your channel's
done do nothing
let the claim expire if they don't
respond in 30 do you know what i love
whenever i've heard this though if they
don't respond 30 days that their claim
review will expire you don't need to do
anything
every time i've heard that it just
happened with our snyder cut trailer
reaction
it's like day 29 is when they get back
to you
they're like no claims still valid you
know you can't have it
they just make sure the 30 days are
almost up
they do specify lastly even though we do
not
mediate in the dispute process we do
investigate
copyright owners that are reportedly
abusing our copyright tools and
processes
we take your feedback seriously and we
want to make sure that your points are
taken into consideration
thank you means a lot
so he's basically going over like i hear
about the things they're saying and then
maybe they're abusing the
the the system and whatnot like that's
that's basically what he's acknowledging
however he's clearly stating that
they're not this is
all in the hands of the person who made
the claim so these people who make the
cl
like that's what i find ridiculous
i kind of feel like you know i don't do
am i wrong for feeling this way is
this is a bad inclination to have that
if
you know this is happening on youtube
and you're fighting this it shouldn't
just be in the hands of the claimant it
should also be someone in youtube the
mediator the decider to go wait a minute
yeah
actually this is not an okay claim to
make and why i have
zero faith in these groups which i'm
gonna flash up on screen again
right now is because i looked them up
john and i we sent out emails to each
one of these companies
very polite can't say it's the same tone
we're taking
right now they're very polite emails
from researching them
all these threads that i was finding
these guys have been dicks for such a
long time and like i've seen their names
pop up on our copyright claims many a
time
they've been doing crap like this for
for
such a long time so for you to be like
yeah we'll investigate i'm like how many
complaints have you had about these guys
how many complaints have you had
from people like me about these groups
doing things like this and you
and it doesn't change it's years it's
been going on
so you know i appreciate the kind words
but beware if you get these manual
claims
it's not in the hands of youtube it's in
the hands of the claimant
i don't really know how to end this
other than i'm just
kind of baffled by i was really under
the impression from my first interaction
with creator support
that there would be a youtube individual
to be
helping mediate the process here on
whether or not
you know the claim is actually valid
come to find out now it's going to be
these companies so that means if i talk
in
a rhythm like this i can get a copyright
claim it's a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
but that's the way youtube works
anyway guys this is stupid i know
there's like bigger copyright issues we
gotta worry about
these days but
[Music]
whoa
you